the money all the time
[Music]
okay Paula it's time for confessions now
nothing's too deep just a few little
questions here yeah what is your go-to
cheat meal or Comfort meal like what do
you create Taco Bell talk about you're
like I'm on it I know don't do it
frequently right but every once in a
while they're Mexican pizzas are my
favorite they must be a dough you know
this who was the most famous person in
your phone and what was the last thing
you texted or called him about I have
lots of famous people in life because
yeah I know I got non-stop WhatsApp
calls and I hit decline decline I don't
know who this person is and then by
accident like on the fourth time I hit
except by accident and there was Eric
Stone Street Scooter Braun Katy Perry
Demi Lovato and President Bill Clinton
what
like I do it again in those WhatsApp
group what shows are you currently
binging or would you recommend others to
binge I'm the queen of suggesting shows
and everyone loves what I suggest
um I'm I just are watching George and
Tommy George uh
love the actors oh I sure do love the
looks my favorite show is Ted lasso just
waiting for the new seasons to start
you're a godsend Ted lasso shit's creek
an all-time favorite I just want them to
hurry up and make a movie yeah it's time
David I cannot show you everything okay
well can you show me one thing can we
get a weekly Paula's pick segment you
can just tell us what you're watching
what is a habit or Quirk that you have
that drives your friends or family
members nuts I laughed so hard I'll pee
in my pants which is not always the most
welcoming gesture
um well sometimes I'll snort when I
laugh I can make really weird faces that
crack them up all the time
they're like no comments they're like no
comment